CHRIS PRATT
When I first came on to play Peter Quill,
the Guardians of the Galaxy were like,
you know, this ragtag squad of nobodies.
JAMES GUNN
I turned in my first draft of
the screenplay, and I was really afraid.
But I felt good about it.
KEVIN FEIGE
People didn't understand why we were doing
that space movie with
a tree and a raccoon.
DAVE BAUTISTA
I think the Guardians are so imperfect,
their pasts are not squeaky clean.
KEVIN FEIGE
This found family putting trauma
behind them to become their best selves.
There's something really special
about that.
KAREN GILLAN
I looked around the other day
and was just like, this casting is
so right. Like, how did they do that?
How did they find us all?
ZOE SALDAÑA
For each and every one of us
to live within the Marvel Universe,
it's been very, very special.
Everybody always comes to work
with the same level of excitement
since day one.
We are very much committed to
James' vision. He's a great captain.
He really believes in this story.
JAMES GUNN
Welcome to Guardians of the Galaxy!
[Cheering]
POM KLEMENTIEFF
You know, we have so much fun
because there is so much
comedy in it and so much emotion.
SEAN GUNN
Being on set with everyone,
knowing that there's a finality
to the whole experience
really made me very emotional.
JAMES GUNN
I mean, we're a family.
They're all people that
I want to keep in my life.
CHRIS PRATT
To be part of something that's just
so universally beloved, it's special.
It's hard to even put into words.
It's been a blast.
PETER QUILL
Are you ready?
Woohoo!
DRAX
Yeah!